people say that like Oh like we're doing
this because black girls can do ballet
so this is the alternative it has
nothing to do with that I will tell you
every girl in this studio is classically
trained everyone does ballet and
everything else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is the Pearl Wilson and I'm a
Hitler dancer Hitler is a mixture of
hip-hop and ballet but really anything
that we can try to put on point that
have like a groovy feeling to it
my name is Omaha's Brian and I'm the
founder of hip leg and the founder and
director of the Chicago multicultural
Dance Center I think some people get mad
where we see a student hit play it's not
traditional classical ballet we're
ruining ballet well no it's not ballet
is hip flick it's how we empower our
kids is how we empower the world hip leg
is so freeing and so open there's a
different culture here no Hitler
movements are the hip flick struck the
twist in and out the moonwalk the Vivian
and the zippy you have to have a certain
posture when you're doing ballet usually
here up tall like straight figure
posture everything pointe shoes were
designed for ballet pitch way is
different a hip lay you can break that
you can just really move your torso more
you can bounce with it you know you can
have fun with it I grew up thinking that
I couldn't do ballet because of the
color of my skin that's my old studio
because I was african-american I was
often overlooked until I came to scene
DC is when I really learned that there
was something off I'm grateful to
Mission a homeroom because he showed me
that I can do anything I love dancing
and hip flick it just gives you a sort
of a confidence and just a freedom like
just to be yourself this is the dance
genre that does not discriminate
we have rhythm and you can groove on
point you got it
[Music]
my way of expressing myself has always
been physical my mom told me was like
since I was little it's like if I would
be angry or happy or whatever you would
see it in in my body language for me
having a new way of challenging my buddy
a new way of pushing the limits of my
what my body can do that was the thing
that really got me hooked in flying
my name is Inga DITA and I'm a dancer
and a world champion indoor skydiver
I started dancing when I was three years
old and as long as I remember I've been
dancing when indoor skydiving came along
I found something for the first time
that I was more passionate about than I
ever was about dancing suddenly I
realized like I've just found a new way
of dancing it's just on a different kind
of dance floor the discipline that I
compete in is called freestyle but when
I'm speaking about my flying overall I
prefer to use the term air dancing
because it's not just about competing
and that set discipline it's about
creating something new exploring the
limits of what we can do in flying and I
would like to take flying from being a
sport towards being a form of performing
arts flying for sure is way harder than
it looks like the wind speeds can go up
to 180 miles an hour you have to be
strong you have to be flexible a lot of
the body positions look easy but they
actually require a lot to perform them
nicely so a split for example it might
look like I'm just resting in in that
flexible body position but I'm actually
all the time pushing against the airflow
to have control
[Music]
I don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sounds like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're gonna get good
I've always been like a hard worker
myself so if I really want to get good
at something I'm gonna do whatever it
takes it just depends on how much you
want it
you
[Music]
lion dancing dates back to the Tang
Dynasty in China I was really meant to
war off the evil spirits and welcome the
good ones I am a 20-something year old
millennial but I still hold this piece
of tradition grab three rings and make
three lines I was born and raised in
Chinatown we do have a lot of the
Chinese traditions that they've come
over and carried on and passed on to us
why Nancy is really important to China
because it is a traditional sport it's
something that a lot of people do come
out and they celebrate around Chinese
New Year typically includes at least two
people per set and a lion you'll have
somebody who plays the lion head and
then somebody will play the tail when
you first come in and you walk through
the door you can't just make up a lion
head it takes about a year for you to be
able to work your way up to that level
kung-fu is the foundation of lion dance
their stances and their leg work is
extremely important we're having you
trained in your footwork in your stances
making sure that you're strong enough to
physically hold yourself through routine
but also a lion head because a lion head
is heavy typically anywhere between
fifteen to thirty pounds typically we
teach different routines for each of the
Lions just because you never know which
one you're going to play it
you can see this line dancing in the
streets anytime where there is a
community event will usually partaking
them in Chinatown a lot of people are
familiar with line dancing and they get
really pumped and excited for it so just
the energy in the atmosphere for me is
ten times better
it's really important for all of us of
that we are educated about line dancing
we do carry it on just because it is
kind of a lost art here in America for
me when I do have children one day I
would like to pass that on to them as
well I think it's really important I
think it's what makes our family our
family
[Music]
what I feel and I am dancing I feel free
I just feel confident I feel strong I
feel in control of Who I am
I knew this is what I wanted to do I
didn't want to do anything else but it
may be
[Music]
my name is Akira Armstrong and I'm the
CEO and founder a pretty big movement
which is a full-figured professional
dance company I started a pretty big
movement nine years ago and I felt that
there was a void and mainstream media
where wasn't a platform for plus-sized
professional dancers I didn't fit in
even walking into auditions I didn't
feel like I belong
the typical expected body type is the
ballerinas you know the long legs and
long arms long torso it's upsetting that
society puts this label on dancers
because for me it's about the talent I
had booked this major gig with Beyonce I
decided well let me audition for more
representation I auditioned for at least
five different agencies and they all
kept saying the same thing she's good
but we don't know how to market her and
I got tired of hearing that even though
I struggle with things it was my passion
it's something that I wanted to do is
something that I love and I kept pushing
and kept pushing and kept pushing and it
just got to a point where I was like
this is really what I want to do we came
up with the name pretty big and from
there I said I need a pack of girls who
know how to move who know how to dance
we have a range of young ladies who are
professional dancers they work hard to
prove themselves not only to me but also
to themselves one thing is that we do is
our pretty big movement workshop anybody
is welcome to come to our workshops I am
pretty big
and I am powerful because I feel nothing
but love in this room
we do power circles and that portion of
the workshop becomes very emotional each
and every day
we have had people say I be divorced
I've been suicide I was a rape victim I
beat cancer so I wasn't gonna let this
fight
they just kind enough to just spill it
all out the misconceptions that people
have about plus-sized women we are lazy
we have low self-esteem we don't care
about our appearance we are non-existent
and we exist
this is Who I am plus-sized and fabulous
oh boy
hula is the language of the heart and
therefore the heartbeat of the Hawaiian
people and we tell our dancers
everything needs steps your hair your
toenail their eyelashes it needs to
dance now you only go if I hey MA
[Music]
[Applause]
within three days the competition
tickets are sold out those tickets are
like gold they only bring the best of
the best and so we're very honored to be
able to participate the most prestigious
part of Merrie Monarch is the missile
above hula competition which is the
women's solo competition 12 hollows are
allowed to choose their very best answer
our contestant this year is chemical any
car can you many is a professional hula
dancer and which was heard for many
different reasons we wanted for the pool
not just the dancer but as a person you
had no cold yeah
one of my favorite parts about Merrie
Monarch week is that we go to Kilauea to
pay respects to Pele with the fire
goddess the goddess of creation and it
really puts into perspective where you
are in this world and in this hula
journey
[Music]
I've wanted to be in Mary marks since I
was a little kid there was a lot of
times where I thought I would never it
would never happen for me but pretty
much most of my hula journey has been
working towards this moment which is
tomorrow professionally I've been doing
it since 2009 there's a difference
between dancing hula and Hollow and
dancing with a professionally authentic
for the tourist is like American Chinese
and not the authentic Chinese food and
hotels here's what you'll see beautiful
men and women brightly colored hair
pieces and leis which are all plastic
but you won't see the skill you won't
see the love that you would at the
Merrie Monarch festival for Merrie
Monarch we practice every day for I
would say 3 to 4 months they're intense
can we try to and one more time what you
think waiting invitation you need one
invitation come on you guys get your
head game on the biggest misconception
about hula I said it's easy all hula
dancers and you quote me on this have
bad knees all of them so when you see a
beautiful hula dancer it's gliding
across the stage she's hurting she's
hurting really bad
because nobody walks around with bent
knees you know six inches off the ground
blisters you get blisters on your feet
every single part of your body needs to
work you should be gasping for air but
you can you need to look exactly the
same as when you first started
you can bend your knees and swing your
hips and have this upper body carriage
that's really upgrade but make it look
effortless that's what you wanna mention
ladies and gentlemen welcome
so this allahu la competición if I gave
the performance of a lifetime if I gave
everything I had to that one performance
those 14 minutes up there just me
you're just the vessel for all of these
people that came before you for all of
the knowledge that you have and it's
your responsibility to share that is
your responsibility to perpetuate but it
would be so nice to hear my name being
called
I know ladies are doing this Allah for
2016
Kaylie
[Applause]
you know I don't dance hula just to be a
missile Ola I do it because I just
because I love it and III can't explain
to you why I do I think I think it's
something you're just learning
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]